à partir de ce samedi démarre le
printemps de la plaine c'est la
troisième édition après une première
édition donc en 2012 un automne de la
peine en toujours en 2012 et pour en
parler avec nous aujourd'hui dominique
baudis bonjour je vous êtes
organisatrice de la manifestation le
printemps donc de la plaine à versailles
une manifestation qui démarre jeudi ce
samedi qui dure jusqu'au 30 juin et
qu'est-ce que globalement les gens vont
pouvoir voir tendance et c'est moi il ya
donc on espère
on espère effectivement bien nous nous
promènerons nous les invitons à venir
découvrir la plaine de versailles à
travers plusieurs manifestations dans
différents villages puisqu'à 24 villages
sur la plaine tous ne participent pas à
l'édition bien sûr mais c'est une façon
de découvrir autrement en allant chez
les producteurs en faisant connaissance
avec le patrimoine en se promenant en
assistant à des spectacles puisque cette
année nous avons intégré un côté plus
culturelle dans notre dans notre édition
2013 avec la présence de jean de la
fontaine alors jean marc fontaine
pourquoi alors jean de la fontaine est
parmi nous il est évident d'affronter le
mal aimé de versailles puisqu'il n'est
jamais rentré à versailles louis xiv lui
a préféré est lui en voulaient beaucoup
de d'avoir été le l'ami de fouquet et
donc
il n'a jamais pu être bienne bien en
cours donc c'est une façon de le
réhabiliter aux portes de versailles
jean de la fontaine mal-aimé du temps du
roi à versailles les met en tout cas par
l'association de la plaine de vercel
puisqu'il est au coeur de cette
manifestation qui va donc durer jusqu'au
30 juin vous avez parlé de cette plaine
de versailles qui regroupe 24 communes
en tout ces dix-huit mille hectares dont
elie mille hectares de terres agricoles
pour cent trente mille habitants sur ce
secteur de la plaine de versailles
quelque part c'est un peu un acte
militant dans votre association c'est
qu'avant on préserve les terres
agricoles sur un territoire où je
précise quand il ya des communes qui
sont assez organisés qui font partie de
la plaine de versailles à
saint-cyr-l'ecole y rappelait avec les
mets tout près de nous dans ces zones
très urbanisées mariatou faut protéger
ses terres alors au départ l'association
s'est appelée
agriculteurs et citadins et
l'association patrimoniale la plaine ne
verse pas le plateau d alu et est le
prolongement de cette de cette première
association qui a voulu intégrer les
citadins dans la plaine et rapprocher
des agriculteurs des citadins c'est une
façon de ceux de mieux se connaître et
mais de protéger aussi le territoire
nous vivant et vous parlez de ces
communes un petit peu
conséquente que son plaisir et d'autres
communes de la plaine de versailles mais
au départ elle n'était il a fallu les
convaincre parce que elle tournait
plutôt le dos à la plaine mais elles se
sont rendu compte de l'atout que
représente et la plaine versailles pour
elle et c'était une façon pour elle cet
état un plus en termes de qualité de vie
en termes d'image et on peut compter
maintenant sur elle adhérer à
l'association patrimoniale l'apn
versailles c'est effectivement un acte
militant parce que c'est une certaine
éthique une certaine façon de voir les
choses est de tout faire pour protéger
la plaine où nous vivons dit rapprocher
les citoyens des agriculteurs à mener
c'est le citoyen l'agriculteur les élus
mais du coup votre association
fonctionne votre action patrimonial
français dans trois collèges et un
collage d'agriculteurs oui une
cinquantaine de huy l'agriculteur un
collège donc des luttes d'élus les 24
mai et puis un collège de d'associations
et de particuliers moi j'y participe en
tant que
association puisque je m'occupe d'une
association de protection du patrimoine
dans un village de la plaine et si vous
les gens y habitant déjà depuis 40 ans
donc j'ai eu envie de m'investir un
petit peu de ce côté là voilà vous avez
déjà venir oui c'est ça ça charmant
petit village de protéger oui oui oui il
m'arrive est déjà loin de plaisir pour
ce qu'il peut j'ai essayé parce que j'ai
été élu pendant 12 ans j'ai essayé de
faire tout ce que je pouvais au moment
où je l'étais pour protéger je continue
c'est le prolongement de cette action
maintenant alors comment on peut faire
pour résister à la pression immobilière
alors certes vous avez convaincu les
élus d'adhérer à cette association qui
on l'a compris une démarche éthique un
arrière votre association mais comment
on fait pour résister à la pression de
me dire quand par exemple un agriculteur
voilà il est en fin d'activité
il n'a pas forcément repreneur parce que
c'est un métier difficile donc là pas
forcément le repreneur il a peut-être le
promoteur qui toquent à sa porte tu as
fais en jeu vous rachète les à-côtés
rabon prise voilà donc faire justement
c'est un problème que nous avons en ce
moment avec un agriculteur de la plaine
de versailles et il a à coeur on
essayant de liquider sa situation
puisqu'il doit cesser son activité de
faire en sorte que ça ne parte pas entre
les mains de n'importe qui si je puis
dire donc les maires des communes
avoisinantes
ce concert tu vois ce qu'ils peuvent
faire et interviennent avec la safer et
tous les organismes qui s'occupent des
terres agricoles pour essayer de faire
en sorte qu'elle échappe à une un
promoteur et à tout ce qui pourrait
aller dans un sens contraire à ce que
souhaite la plaine de versailles tombola
une vraie l'action politique donc dans
ce sens là oui dans ce sens là il ya une
charte paysagère participatif qui est en
cours oui de rédaction il ya votre
assemblée générale qui je crois se tire
dans la rue beauchêne prochain oui
quel est le but de cette charte
paysagère justement c'est une façon de
l'opposer au ceux qui voudraient se
laisser aller à construire un petit peu
trop sur notre territoire parce qu'elle
est elle fera à signer de toul et de
tous les élus et ce sera une une façon
de c'est un peu opposable aux
aux appétits des promoteurs
alors j'avais une question aujourd'hui
peut-être la pause octobre et but votre
association s'appelle l'association
patrimoniale de la plaine de versailles
il veut à tous les élus et de la vallée
de la mauldre voilà c'était que
légèrement compliqué les rides complet
d'image mais radieux sur le mot
versailles parce que versailles ne fait
pas partie de l'association n'ont alors
oui c'est moi nous appelons la plaine de
verse pas faim on essaye de simplifier
parce que pour le
celui qui n'est pas au courant c'est un
sigle absolument imprononçable donc on
dit plutôt plaine de versailles voilà
pourquoi versailles n'est pas dans le
versailles c'est très important par
rapport à nous et en tant que commune
non rural vous vous en doutez bien ne
peut pas prétendre aux subventions
qui concerne les comptes les communes
rurales comme nous par ce concept de
l'arizona également de subventions
européennes
voilà parce qu'il ya un programme hors
pair j'ai découvert ça avec vous il ya
un centre européen va à fond européen
des deux communes rurales et nous avons
postulé pour pouvoir pour pouvoir en
bénéficier et nous avons pu le faire
donc c'est un programme qui dure cinq
ans il arrive à échéance fin 2013 mais
il est prolongé donc les actions peuvent
être prolongées et pour nous c'est
extrêmement intéressant parce que ça
nous permet d'aider
les agriculteurs les municipalités les
individuels lorsqu'ils ont des projets
intéressants qui s'insère bien dans le
programme de la plaine de versailles de
les aider quand vous d'aidé individuelle
c'est quoi par exemple un
cas particulier peut mettre en place
pour bah si on a une une opération de de
prévention enfin bon les individuels
sont plutôt rattaché d'une façon ou
d'une autre à une association mais c'est
quand même une façon de
de pouvoir
de pouvoir les aider par exemple les
agriculteurs agriculteurs qui a un
projet de transformation de dans son
atelier de transformation de ces
produits peut faire me déposer une
demande de subvention tout ça est soumis
à accord bien entendu d'un certain
nombre de deux organismes mais par le
biais des fonds européens il peut
peut-être ouvrir son atelier de
transformation soit c'est un exemple
parmi parmi d'autres donc ça aura
soutien vous apporter c'est bon c'est
pas simplement une association
culturelle à noyen draps du tout il
reste du chemin et on est tous bénévoles
à l'intérieur de cette de cette
association et
voilà ça nous permet le printemps de la
plaine nous permet de faire découvrir
d'autres richesses à aux habitants de la
plaine et à travers tout un ensemble de
manifestations qui vont d'un bout à
l'autre de la plaine et qui recouvre
aussi bien
la découverte des sentiers de randonnée
la découverte du patrimoine on a une par
exemple une vie de grignan le château de
grignan est fermé depuis la tempête de
99 donc c'est une façon de l'ouvrir et
de pouvoir faire une visite il y a bon
vous avez des promenades écologique
aussi avec sur les sentiers de randonnée
il y a des arts 1 et dès qu'ils
synthétisent ceux qui participent à lyon
précise également alors je rappelle sur
le printemps de la plaine de versailles
ça démarre à partir de ce samedi 18 au
30 juin et un site internet je crois
qu'il s'est affichée comme ça les lisons
pas voir toutes les informations et le
programme qui est très complet sur le
site faut aussi préciser que la plupart
des animations sont gratuites favori
tout à fait tout à fait où il a très peu
de manif est enfin il y a pas de droit
d'entrée du tout j'ai fait il ya
quelquefois une petite participation qui
est demandée lors par exemple il ya un
repas qui est prévu alors ce repas est
payant sur réservation mais il est fait
avec les produits des producteurs donc
le traiteur qui nous fait le repas joue
le jeu il va chercher tel ou tel ou tel
produit chez les différents producteurs
de la plaine et ça c'est une vraie
réalité oui les gens veulent des des
produits locaux et les habitants locaux
il ya là une vraie d'identification
agricole de deux territoires de plus en
plus oui et nous avons une carte
justement des producteurs qui est
accessible à tout le monde où les gens
peuvent voir les producteurs qui font
des ventes à la ferme et qui sont aussi
sur les marchés bien sûr delà de la
région merci à dominique vous êtes venu
sur le plateau du 7-8 week-end dont je
rappelle le printemps de la plaine de
versailles ça démarre à partir de ce 23
mars et jusqu'au 30 juin là toutes les
informations sur le site internet merci
beaucoup de nous en parler